متلازمه مرضيه حيرت العالم دامت لسنوات
دون جواب يعاني منها فقط الدبلوماسيون
الامريكيون القصه بدات من هافانا الكوبيه
عام 2016 بعد بحث وتحليل لسنوات خلصت
تحقيقات اجرتها وكالات والاستخبارات
الامريكيه الى ما يعرف بمتلازمه هافانا
ليست ناجمه عن سلاحا سري يستهدف
الدبلوماسي لكن سببها الحقيقي ما زال
مجهولا متلازمه هافانا كما وصفها المصابون
تسبب احاسيس صوتيه غريبه ومؤلمه وصداع
ودوار ولم يتوقف الجدل حول اسباب هذه
الظاهره التي يعاني منها اكثر من 1500 شخص
بين من يقول انها نتيجه عن سلاح يستخدم
ويستخدم موجات من الطاقه لاستهداف هؤلاء
الموظفين ومن يعتقد ان مصدرها اسباب
طبيعيه او ضغط عصبي في حين يرى اخرون ان
السبب لا يزال مجهولا المزيد حول قصه هذه
المتلازمه مع زميله هند ابراهيم
ما زاد البحث لمعرفه اسباب متلازمتها
هذانا زاد غموضها لا خصم اجنبيا ولا سلاح
كهرومغناطيسيا وراء المرض الذي يصيب
دبلوماسيين وضباطه مخابرات امريكيين في
بعثات حول العالم بحسب تحقيقات امريكيه في
اكثر من 90 دوله رفعت عنها السريه مؤخرا
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه سي اي ايات اخرى
لم تشكك بتجارب المصابين ومعاناتهم لكنها
وجدت ان من غير المحتمل ان يكون رنين
الاذنين الذي يتبعه ضغط في الراس وقد هيان
وصداع نصفي وكوكبه اخرى من الاعراض ناتجا
عن موجات كهرومغناطيسيه كما انها لم تجد
نمطا موحدا او شروطا متطابقه تربط بين
الحالات الفرديه
[موسيقى]
التقرير الجديد يرى ان الخبراء الطبيين لا
يمكنهم ارجاع الاعراض الى اسباب منفصله عن
حاله الموجوده مسبقا او عوامل بيئيه
وتعرضت تقرير انتقادات ووصف بغير المكتمل
كونه لم ياخذ جميع البيانات ووجهات النظر
بعين الاعتبار بما في ذلك نتائج توصلت
اليها العام الماضي لجنه خبراء مستقله
ونتائج سابقه للاكاديميات الوطنيه للعلوم
والطب افادت بان طاقه التردد النابضه
والموجهه قد تكون خلف هذه الظاهره
شيء ما حدث لاولئك الموظفين يقول وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
فهي ليست هستيريا جماعيه ولا حاله نفسيه
مسؤولون اكدوا ان وكالات الاستخبارات فكرت
في جميع الاحتمالات حتى في ان تكون كائنات
فضائيه وراء هذه الظاهره لكنها استبعدت
هذا الاحتمال لصباح العربيه هند ابراهيم
واشنطن
على كل ينضم لنا المتخصص في الشان
الامريكي والعلاقات الدوليه ايهاب عباس من
واشنطن اهلا بك سيد ايهاب معنا وما قصه
متلازمه هافانا الغامضه التي كانت تلاحق
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيه
صباح الخير لحضرتك
ولكل المشاهدين اين مكانه يعني طبعا هذه
المتلازمه ظهرت قبل ما يقرب من سبعه اعوام
وتسببت في مشكلات كبيره انذاك لانها لم
يكن هناك اي معلومات كافيه من الممكن ان
يبني عليها المسؤولون الامريكيون اسباب
هذه
الاصابه المتعدده التي لحقت بالدبلوماسين
الامريكيين اليوم بعد مرور هذه السنوات
وبعد تحقيقات عده ليس فقط داخل الولايات
المتحده ولكن خارجها ايضا لم يصل
المسؤولون الى اي نتائج يعني
تلوي ظما الذين اصيبوا بهذا المرض الغريب
ولا حتى وكالات الاستخبارات والاجهزه التي
عمل بها هؤلاء
لتعلمهم ما هي الاسباب وهل هناك ضمانه الا
تتكرر هذه الاسباب او هذه
الامور التي حدثت لهم لكن هناك ايضا بحث
جديد لتجريه احدى الجامعات الامريكيه
اليوم
بشكل الفيدرالي
يا ابني هذا البحث اساسه على التجارب على
الفئران
وانواع معينه اخرى من القوارض لتعريضها
لنفس المسببات التي يعتقد بعض المسؤولين
انها هي التي ادت الى هذا المرض الغامض
وينتظرون النتائج حتى يعلموا اذا ما كانت
بالفعل كانت قد تعرضت لاسلحه مختلفه كما
تحدثوا كهرومغناطيسيه استاذ ايهاب
ماذا لو كانت حقيقيه لماذا تمارس على
الدبلوماسيين لا القاده السياسيين اللي هم
اكثر استهدافا من الدبلوماسيين الذين
يعملون كموظفين لدى الاداره الامريكيه لان
هؤلاء يعملون في اماكن خارج الولايات
المتحده فسهل الوصول اليهم يعني يصعب
الوصول الى السلسله الامريكيين داخل
الولايات المتحده لكن الدبلوماسين عاده
يعملون في اماكن طبعا خارج البلاد وخاصه
في دوله مثل كوبا حيث حدث الامر في هافانا
وبعض بالمناسبه السفارات الاخرى الامريكيه
من الممكن ان يكون هناك وصول سهله لهؤلاء
لكن طبعا داخل الولايات المتحده سيكون
الامر صعب جدا بسبب الاجراءات الامنيه
الجديده حول السياسيين سيدي هذا الملفت
انه تم اكتشاف ان هذه الاعراض لم يتعارض
لها الدبلوماسيون في كوبا فقط بل انحاء
مختلفه من العالم بين هالصين بين استراليا
وحتى الدول الاوروبيه كالمانيا اليوم
عندما يتم الحديث انه الاستخبارات
الامريكيه تستبعد امكانيه احتماليه هجوم
اجنبي الى اي مدى هذا يبدو منطقيا
يعني انا اعتقد ان هذا القرار الامريكي
حتى اللحظه ربما مبني على انه ليست هناك
ايه ادله لو كانت لدى واشنطن ادله ولو حتى
بنسبه 5% او عشره بالمئه كان من الممكن ان
توجه اصابع الاتهام الى اي من الدول التي
من الممكن ان تكون تدخل معلومات المتحده
في تنافس دبلوماسي وعسكري وسياسي الى اخره
لكن حتى اللحظه لا توجد ايه ادله لذلك انا
اعتقد ان كل التقارير حتى الان منقوصه حتى
لو خرجت من اكبر اجهزه الاستخبارات
والوكالات الفيدراليه الامريكيه طالما لا
توجد ايه ادله فنحن امام موقف غامض مفتوح
على كل الاحتمالات من بينها حتى الكائنات
الفضائيه
يعني يا استاذ ايهاب ما في دخان من دون
نار وطالما في ادله وفي اجماع على هذه
الادله كمان هل يمكن اعتبارها جزء من
الحرب الخفيه بين الدول التي تمارسها بين
بعضها البعض وان كانت حرب من الفضائيين
طبعا احتمال قائم جدا هي المشكله اليوم
اننا ليس لدينا ايه ادله لكن لذلك اقول
انها مفتوحه على كافه الاحتمالات من
الممكن في نهايه المطاف نجد الولايات
المتحده تتهم دوله مثل الصين مثل كوريا
الشماليه مثل كوبا نفسها ممكن ان تتهم
منظمات تعمل لمصلحه دول من الممكن ان تتهم
روسيا يعني
الاحتمالات ستكون قائمه واعتقد ان البحث
الذي يجري الان في احدى الجامعات على
الفئران والقوارد ربما ياتي بنتائج
ايجابيه خلال الفتره القادمه من الممكن ان
تؤدي ان يكون هناك امام المسؤولين
الامريكيين بعض الادله تساعدهم في الكشف
عن حقيقه محمد طالما يا استاذ ايهاب يعني
الفضائيين في سؤال خارج السياق بما انه
ختمنا متلازمه هافانا لماذا دائما
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تروج لفكره
انها مستهدفه هي من الفضائيين في الاونه
الاخيره
ظهر الحديث عن المركبات الفضائيه والان
حتى طلبت متلازمه هافانا بالفضائيين لماذا
فقط
ربما الفضائيين يحبون الهمبرجر اكثر من اي
شيء
الفضائيين ربما اكيد طبعا اكيد ههه
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر استاذ ايهاب عباس
المتخصص في شان الامريكي والعلاقات
الدوليه شكرا لك